Trump captured on tape talking about
classified document he kept after
leaving the White House the details here
are critical Federal prosecutors have an
audio recording from a meeting in summer
of 2021 remember this is after Trump
left the White House in which former
president Trump acknowledges he held on
to a classified Pentagon document about
a potential attack on Iran multiple
sources told CNN undercutting his
argument that he Declassified everything
remember Trump said I Declassified
everything I took but in this audio
recording Trump actually says this is
classified I can't show it to you
therefore he did not declassify it the
recording indicates Trump understood
that he retained classified material
after leaving the White House on the
recording Trump's comments suggests he
would like to share the information but
he's aware of limitations on his ability
post-presidency to declassify records
two of the sources said